if you were still trapped in a survival
game where you and 11 others could
predict when you'll die what would you
do i'm here to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the mobile death game in future diary
part two but let's cool it on
customizing our future with diaries for
a second and let's talk about today's
sponsor opera gx other browsers aren't
nearly as customizable or as capable as
opera gx is so go crazy go check out
their wallpapers their colors you can
even upload your very own background
photo which is so nice and weebs go
check out their animated wallpaper
through their opera add-ons we've got
spirited away we've got demon slayer
we've got hunter hunter and so much more
also os browser design silliness
shouldn't get in the way of you watching
your anime no no no no instead opera jx
gives you the power to separate the
video from the browser which will allow
you to surf work study and do it all
while watching anime at the same time
meaning more time with anime and more
gaming because this browser also comes
with twitch and discord integration
which is so cool and it also comes with
an award-winning design and an even free
vpn let me say that again a free vpn
this browser's gx player is also
designed to stream your favorite
streaming services all in one place i'm
talking apple music i'm talking spotify
i'm talking youtube and whenever you're
streaming audio or video gx will auto
pause and resume once the tab is
finished designed for quick import you
can import everything you need from the
previous browser browsing history
bookmarks cookies import imported in a
matter of seconds so use my link to
download opera gx today and thank you
opera gx for sponsoring this video yuki
here is the unluckiest guy in the world
he's been entered into a death game with
11 others and given a virtual diary on
his phone that can predict the future
however in this game if your diary
breaks you die the creator of this
mobile death game is deus a literal god
that is slowly dying as well only one
lucky contestant will be chosen and they
will take his place as god of the entire
world akisa knocks on yuki's door to
find that he's not home and that's when
the detective's assistant rolls up in a
car and tells him to hop inside before
the trip the assistant tells akisa that
he's been researching the contestants of
this survival game he believes that yuno
took yuki to a remote location to
protect him from other diary owners the
next day akisay brings yuki's friends to
meet the assistant who tells them what's
going on since they have diaries the
police woe to be able to search them
without being found out the group agrees
to help but the task is more complicated
than it seems the resort is made up of
several small towns full of abandoned
buildings the group decides to split up
to make the search faster in one of the
buildings cosica complains that there's
no running water and akisay has a light
bulb moment and realizes that they can
narrow down the list of searchable
places by checking those that still have
working electricity and water what
there's got to be a better way to do
this to find our runaway couple instead
of searching every single dang hotel
with our group akisa is a smart kid yes
but for a world famous detective this
isn't one of his brightest moments
taking our time means yuki is with yuno
another second another minute you know
could go awol at any time and if yuki
dies the world is doomed if i was akise
i would have asked the detective
assistant to bring along some of his
buddies from the police station under
the intent that psycho girl has our
friend locked up in an abandoned hotel
that girl is nuts and truly insane her
protection of yuki she is just as much
of a walking time bomb to yuki as she is
a shield for him japan is a country not
known for its widespread crime so it's
safe to assume that there should be a
few officers that are having a slow day
not only that it doesn't matter how well
you can deduce their location if the hot
spring resort is comprised of multiple
towns all with dozens of potential
hotels motels and nasty twenty dollar bl
motels where our kidnapped friend might
be staying at just look at the size of
this place now if we estimate that we
only have a single day to find them
we're going to be mostly relying on luck
to find the exact spot that juno has
taken him this is all considering the
fact that freak show yuno is obsessed
with yuki and somehow hasn't been
informed that we're looking for them
already which would likely cause her to
go somewhere else both groups find
themselves in the same hotel on
different floors they open the elevators
just to avoid a pickaxe swinging out
suddenly the lights turn off and the
boys realize they need to leave this
hotel for their own safety meanwhile the
girls receive a message that tells them
yuki is trapped in the basement of the
grand hotel hinata runs off alone to
find him the others meet up without her
to discuss the text akisay tells them it
was faked by yuno hinata here took the
bait that's when they receive a text
from her saying that she's found yuki
aki say here is skeptical but they run
off to go find them running into the
grand hotel they make their way into a
room with an unconscious yuki tied up
they try to wake him but his head
suddenly falls off it's a trap and the
ex-bully kosoka just walks in and locks
the door that's when poison gas begins
to seep out of the containers shocked
akisa notices a surveillance camera and
sends a message to yuno he asks her if
she has two skulls with her and says
that he went back to her house after she
and yuki left he tells everyone that he
found human remains hidden in a massive
hole in her garden however two of the
bodies were missing their skulls enraged
yuno reveals that those were her parents
remains akize interrupts her to ask
about the third body finding it strange
that only one of the bodies still had
its head screwed on he proposes that he
won't tell the police if she releases
everyone threatening to send a text to
the police right now but she doesn't
respond kosaka sends out one final text
but he's used up all of his posts
suddenly the blog notifies him that he's
ranked up and has been given future
diary functions kosaka now owns the
apprentice diary shocked they check it
out to find a text which shows how they
can get out of this room and find yuki
kosaka crawls through the vent and out
to the security room finding yuno and
the others tied up suddenly yuka here
begins to wake up and remembers exactly
what happened when they went on their
trip yuno gave him a poison can of coke
causing him to pass out on the spot once
he woke up he was trapped in this room
kosaka reveals that he has a diary and
it predicts that he frees everyone and
saves the day you know admits defeat and
tells him that she'll hand over the keys
in exchange for her parents skulls
kosaka checks the diary to make sure
everything's okay and agrees as she
hands over the key to the gas room he
unlocks it but loses sight of yuno who
shoots him with a crossbow she explains
that his diary is weak only showing how
he can succeed not how he can fail
she has a point while getting your own
future diary is a blessing in and of
itself sometimes the biggest blessings
can end up being your biggest curse why
did he turn his back to her she is a
literal spazoid who's obsessive about
yuki to the point that she's willing to
turn him into a vegetable and spoon-feed
him for the rest of his days in a dingy
basement it's only me and psycholady and
it doesn't look like anyone is coming to
help us right away the prediction on our
phone is to release yuki but if it looks
like a trap smells like a trap and
sounds like a trap then it probably is
while a crossbow bolt to the lake is
pretty damn painful at least it's not a
gun once she fires the shot it takes her
time to reload the second one if we
don't do anything fast then we might get
another bolt stuck in our throat if it
were me i'd not follow what our phone is
saying anytime soon we're physically
compromised so the element of surprise
is the only thing we have we have three
options option one the closest thing to
us is a chair i'd grab it and have it
between me and yuno now she has to land
a perfect shot through the spaces in the
backrest of the chair to get to me the
best case we block the shot and talk to
you buying our friends time to get to us
while we wait for a better opportunity
option two when she turns her back to us
and sees yuki not in the chair we grab
the skull in the chair closest to us and
we hit her in the side of the head as
hard as we possibly can best case she
dies worst case she's disoriented and we
take the crossbow load it and shoot her
option three since we're a subsidiary
diary owner that means we might be able
to break our phones without the fear of
losing our life of course we would lose
our predictive capabilities as we
wouldn't have a phone to read them from
that being said i would throw my phone
directly at yuno's head while it's
extremely far-fetched and has a 99.9
chance of failure sitting around and
doing nothing has 100 chance of us dying
if we're lucky we somehow might be able
to hit her in the right spot and knock
her out and we are now crowned a hero by
our friends yuno threatens to kill him
and turns to see that yuki's chair is
empty he appears from the side and grabs
her crossbow slapping her in the face he
tells her that her diary is limited as
well since it didn't inform her that
hinata had kicked him the key to the
chair suddenly he gets a text saying
that three diary owners are coming his
way the groups reunite and freaky yuno
here begs yuki to stay with her he tells
her to f off and walks out with his
friends the next day yuki asks deus
about these new diary owners according
to him the 8th diary is on a server and
she's continuously making new subsidiary
diary owners that's when yuki gets a new
text from his diary three subsidiary
diary owners will be coming to his home
in three days time they decide that
hiding him in kosaka's house is the best
option for his safety akisay tells him
that they'll try to figure out a plan to
stop the three subsidiary diary owners
from killing him but there's only one
issue you know her diary tells her
exactly what yuki's doing so the chance
of her getting involved is extremely
high three days later the group takes
him to kosaka's place as originally
planned they talk about leaving police
around the perimeter to keep him safe
but they know it's not going to help
with the diary owners when they arrive
at the house they notice a cell phone
antenna tower which in theory would be
able to cut off the subsidiary diary
owner's abilities the group waits in the
house until evening and gets ready for
the three to force their way in suddenly
they see them running towards them
through the field and they get ready to
activate the antenna but someone cut the
power and the remote control doesn't
work wondering who the hell cut the
power they see yuno walk out of the
house and promise to protect yuki akisay
tells him that he and kosaka will go and
physically cut the signal on the antenna
okay that's a whole lot to take in
people are coming to kill us crazy girl
is back for more and the group has
decided that hiding us in a massive
mansion with a ton of blind spots is the
best way to beat these diary owners to
the punch great while our friends are
trying their best to keep me safe their
best is not enough we may have involved
the police in our cause but there's
still a good chance that whoever wants
to find us can find us heck who knows
maybe these guys even have drones
overhead that are watching our every
move since we have a lot of people
trying to keep us safe why not go the
extra mile and do something foolproof
that will ensure our safety for at least
a little bit other than going to school
there's nothing stopping us from simply
hopping on a flight and getting the hell
out of dodge i'm pretty sure that would
be more effective than using the police
currently stationed around kosaka's
house i would have to make sure we
safely hop on a plane without the entire
airport getting bombed while there may
be diary owners coming after us i'm
pretty sure the airport security will be
too much for them to handle and they
don't want to be on national news
chasing some kid juno here is tied up to
keep them safe they walk back into the
house and see the assistant blown
through the door two of the diary owners
walk in and spot yuki right above these
are the sevenths the assistant rushes
the man and gets knocked out meanwhile
the group climbs up to the attic to
escape but the diary owners are on their
tail yugi and yuno managed to make it up
but that's when she closes the attic
door shut she tells them to untie her so
she can handle business yuki is hesitant
though the diary owners make their way
into the attic and akisay cuts the
signal on the antenna disabling their
phones the diary owners are shocked but
pull out another phone and reveal that
their diaries are still working they
knew their plan the entire time and
played dumb with that the sevens easily
take yuki and yuno out and take their
diaries the next day half of the group
is in the hospital and the mission a
complete failure yuki and yuno's diaries
have been taken by the seventh and yuno
has been out ever since the nurse
arrives and sits on the bed asking yuki
what diaries the enemy was using
suddenly she takes off her wig and
reveals herself to be the ninth well
that went well that protection mission
went horribly wrong and it looks like
we're screwed for the time being however
at least we know the identities of
another diary user and they're very
unique now while it might seem like a
pretty bad situation especially with our
walking psycho you know being down and
out it might be a good time to catch up
on some r r it's been traumatic chaos
ever since we got these diaries and it
might do us some good to chill out
looking at the type of injuries we took
we could be suffering from the effects
of a concussion post-concussion protocol
states that a person takes at least one
or two days off from rest followed by
light exercise we might be surrounded by
gods and crazy situations and
power-hungry wackos but sometimes you
just gotta kick back and watch some tv a
few days later the boys leave the ninth
to take care of yuki she tells him that
she'll be preparing him to fight the
sevenths that's when a man interrupts
them to ask if he's found yuki's room
shocked yuki realizes this man is his
father they take a fitness test together
to train for the seventh yuki asks him
why he divorced mom he explains to him
that he was irresponsible with their
money amassing a debt of over 3 million
yen later the father runs inside the
hospital room and tears the room apart
calling a mystery number he asks if his
debt will be erased in exchange for
breaking yuki's phone the next day the
assistant finds the location of the 7th
yugi and his father watched the
situation unfold on live tv and they
hear a ring and yuno picks up the
hospital phone to hear the seventh they
tell her they can see everything they're
doing and tells them to bring the father
or else they'll break their phones the
three of them go to sakurami tower and
walk in to see the seventh dressed in
wedding clothes his father greets them
but gets punched in the stomach by the
man he reveals their phones and tells
them he'll hand them over along with his
if he beats him in a fist fight yuki
rushes towards him but gets held up by
the throat seventh throws him back down
and yuki notices his father trying to
break his phone he snaps the screen off
and yuki screams for his life suddenly
yuna runs towards the lady 7th and
swipes her flowers she realizes that the
phones were fakes and hands yuki's back
to him his father interrupts and begs
him to hand his over he promises that
he'll buy him a new one once he clears
his debt okay first of all the phones
may have been fake but yuki could not
have handled that situation any worse
the seventh is doing us a favor by
inviting us to a fistfight and not
getting the jump on us somewhere out of
the blue but they wouldn't invite us to
where they are if they weren't confident
they'd win the odds are not looking good
with fighting hand-to-hand a bigger
stronger guy now i'd love to say let's
go full on mike tyson john wick mode on
this guy but that's probably a bad plan
there's only a small chance that an
untrained teenager is going to beat this
guy in a fair one-on-one fight we don't
have the size length or experience to
take him head-on the odds are not in our
favor if we're fighting we gotta fight
dirty with yuki being the shorter
fighter when he grabs us by the neck we
gotta be fast and clamp down and bite as
hard as we can ideally biting off a few
fingers it takes the same amount of
pressure to bite off a piece of a carrot
with your teeth as it does to bite off a
finger our legs are free and the only
easy shots we got are to the stomach
crotch and the arm holding us up people
commonly think that shots to the stomach
don't hurt but there are two parts of
the stomach that will incapacitate
somebody if hit the liver and the solar
plexus we either kick him in these spots
or wrap our legs around his arm and push
off of his body even though we're a kid
and lighter than him it's gonna be hard
to hold a 115 pound kid in the air with
his arm straight out if we're lucky we
get a few extra freebie shots to his
face before he lets go of us we've now
messed up his hand good and maybe even
damaged his arm with the weight of our
body being held by one arm if i was yuki
i would start questioning the people in
my life and whether they have a positive
effect on it first of all we got crazy
sago lady who won't leave us alone and
going as far as murder to keep us
together and now my deadbeat dad has
arrived on the scene who's clearly not
here to reconcile our relationship i
would say screw this guy get our phones
and leave him to the seventh that's when
an explosion happens from above and this
man on a loudspeaker tells them he's
blowing up the building suddenly the
floor breaks from beneath yuki both yun
and his father rush to stop him from
falling but she manages to grab on first
the floor breaks from beneath the father
but the sabbath grabs him and they run
upstairs yuki and yuno followed them to
escape the explosion the diary tells
them that they're escaping by parachute
so they follow them in hopes of taking
it for themselves the sevenths leave the
elevator and are surprised to see yuno
on her own the male 7th runs towards her
and knocks her out he picks up her phone
and finds out that yuki's currently in
the broadcast room the male 7th goes to
find him while yuno here tries attacking
the lady's seventh while she's
distracted running into the broadcast
room the man realizes that this was all
planned yuki used the fake phone from
earlier as a decoy he checks his own
diary to see that lady sabbath is about
to die by way of playing darts he rushes
back down to tell his girlfriend to
watch out and she misses the dark throw
by an inch but gets her throat slit by
yuna while distracted she takes the lady
seventh's parachute but the father
swipes it and jumps out of the building
and leaves them to die trapped in the
rubble the lady sabbath tells them that
they're stuck and her boyfriend is going
to win the game yuno threatens to cut
her throat for real this time in order
to make the boyfriend come save her the
plan works and they hear him trying to
push the rocks out of the way so he can
save his girlfriend he tells yuki to
help him by pushing upwards and they
managed to clear the rubble however they
realized that the male 7th has been
brutally wounded and is on his last legs
yugi begs yuno to come help them so they
can successfully push the rock off and
escape certain death the next day the
contestants gather around to take out
the mayor of narukami city they agreed
to band together for one day to kill the
strongest diary user and make the death
game fair however yuki and yuno have
something else up their sleeve later on
yuno sends out a signal to yuki to begin
the operation gathering other
contestants they get ready to take on
the 11th in a temporary alliance he
details his master plan beginning with
himself occupying the mayor with his
random diary from there he'll spread
tear gas while everyone else rushes in
he tells this little girl rin to keep
count of everyone with her orphanage
diary and orders taro here to guard the
eighth and watch himself this man here
has the copy diary meaning he can copy
yuno's diary and find out exactly what
she knows meanwhile the assistant drives
the mayor to his destination and that's
when they get ambushed and the plan is
put into action everything is going well
but a strange device is emitted from the
car the mayor reveals that he set up a
jamming device to stop the apes
subordinates from checking their diaries
suddenly taro notices the man beside him
shooting down his friends yunu comes
running down the hill and chops the
little girl's head clean off okay that
was pretty dang shocking but it might
have been pretty damn stupid while we
might have been able to take out a good
majority of the diary owners this little
betrayal came a little too soon with all
these people banding together we're
missing a prime opportunity to take out
one of the strongest diary owners in the
game if we really wanted to take
everyone out in one fell swoop i'd
potentially make an agreement to have a
ceasefire directly after the mayor and
the eighth are taken out so we have time
to regroup and continue the survival
game of course that would be a bluff so
we can catch them off guard and take
them out when they least expect it the
other diary owners look significantly
less intimidating than the ones in the
car and they also seem to be much less
powerful why else would we need to team
up like this to take them out honestly
all we need to do is to send yuno off to
kill the remaining contestants after
taking out to the mayor's car and
winning the survival game will be a
cinch the entire thing was a trap and
this temporary alliance was just a way
for yuki to get what he wants yuno
fights a dow tauruo stabbing him through
the chest and killing him now everyone
has been taken out except for the matron
she runs into the assistant's car to get
away but yuno finds a card that they can
use to chase them while reading her
diary she realizes that their car is
going to be stopped and akisay will
appear out of nowhere however that's not
all the identity of the third body at
yuno's house will be revealed meanwhile
the 11th knows that they're being chased
and has a plan up his sleeve he directs
the car in and out of traffic but yuno
has an idea she pops out of the window
and readies her gun to hit the tire but
the car manages to dodge her shot yuki
suggests that the 11th diary might be
similar to his showing events around
them but not events that happen to them
okay i understand that they're in a
high-speed car chase and yuno doesn't
have the same shooting capabilities of a
fast and furious character but they
should still be able to derail the
mayor's car with relative ease without
causing any harm to themselves now since
they know that the diary is making it
impossible to hit the tires it might be
better to forget about aiming at them
completely if i was yuki i'd tell yuno
to get back into the car and fasten her
seat belts since we know that the driver
himself isn't a diary owner we can do
something that the mayor will never
expect or maybe he would but either way
he can't stop it from happening we have
multiple opportunities to take these
guys out rear end collisions at low
speeds can prove to be fatal for one
that gets hit if the mayor's car needs
to slow down because there's incoming
vehicles ahead we can charge right into
the back corner of their car and hope to
send it fatally serving off into the
highway assuming the entire highway is
empty which is highly unlikely we can
chase them off the highway and try to
see where they're going who knows both
cars have to stop for gas at some point
and when that happens yuno can whip out
her gun and begin massacring the
defenseless contestants yuno takes the
suggestion and aims her gun straight for
the eleven but the shot still misses
they need to do something quick or else
they'll lose their trail and the entire
plan will be a complete failure yuki
tries rhyming the car against the
railing causing the railing to break and
sending them flying onto another road
taking advantage of the chaos yuno
sticks a gun in the eleventh's face but
he's not finished just yet suddenly two
people make a grand entrance on a
motorcycle they take their helmets off
and reveal themselves as akisai and the
nine he tells them he's been researching
the dna of the third body and he's made
a terrifying discovery he throws yuki a
box found from yuno's orphanage inside
the box is yuno's umbilical cord akisa
here compared the dna of the third body
to the umbilical cord and the dna was
exactly the same the third body belongs
to yuno she's been dead all along he
tells yuki to get away from her but he
doesn't believe him later aki says group
the ninth and the assistant agreed to
team up and take out the 11th who's
located in the quad towers they enter
the towers in separate groups and within
seconds the 11th knows they're already
there okay this is a big deal and we're
going to need to put a lot more thought
into it if we want to stay alive
obviously the mayor is a pretty smart
guy since he's a mayor after all with
the quad towers looking like the tallest
and most expensive buildings in the
entire city who likely gathered more
than enough security to spot us or any
other potential intruders trying to
murder him walking through the front
door of a gigantic headquarters operated
by the mayor of the city is a surefire
way to die instantly so we should at
least try to find some fire exits that
might give us a small element of
surprise however we should be careful to
check if they're openable from the fire
exit itself it would suck to climb a 100
floor staircase and find out that
they're locked out from the outside now
that we've stated the obvious there's
some other preparations that the group
could have taken with a little more time
and thought the first thing we need to
realize is that the mayor is a diary
owner we should expect him to know our
every move before we make it since we
don't know what his diary actually does
we can't plan out much to keep us from
being found however since the world is
going to be reset anyways breaking the
law shouldn't be a problem right the
group should be asking the assistant if
he knows where to get guns how it won't
be easy to get assault rifles or
anything crazy like that but since world
war ii all japanese police officers have
been given handguns which they carry on
duty if we can infiltrate the
assistant's old police station to look
for weapons or even take out a couple of
innocent officers roaming the streets we
can get their guns and use them for
ourselves while it's not much a simple
weapon like this that we could conceal
in our clothes will make our mission a
whole lot easier ninth and the assistant
make their way up the stairs while he
rewrites his diary to throw off the
mayor he watches them through their
surveillance cameras and realizes what's
going on however he has another trick up
his sleeve ninth and the assistant run
through the hallways and get caught off
guard by an explosive the assistant
jumps in front of her to guard her but
she realizes that her hand has been
blown off suddenly he shot through the
chest and falls to the ground she drags
him to the fire exit but the man begs
her to let him die that's when these
guards find where they've been hiding
and instantly shoot he jumps in front of
her and takes multiple gunshots into his
back dying on the spot yuki reveals
himself as the man behind everything he
used the ninth as a decoy and he and
yoona are after the same thing he brings
her to a vault where he swipes a key
card and manages to open the door
however there's still one more door in
the way yuki tries to input random
passcodes to open the second door but
the ninth here decides that the mission
was a failure and points her gun towards
him with fatal wounds the ninth takes
one for the team and reveals her dead
man's switch a bomb will detonate that's
strong enough to break even the vault
door she sits down and waits for herself
to die from blood loss while yuki waits
outside however when the door reopens
nothing has changed the eleventh sits in
his room thinking that he's completely
safe suddenly yuno pops out at the
corner of the room and points a gun at
his head shooting and killing the man
instantly the next day yuki realizes
that there's only one more person he
needs to kill the eighth he checks his
diary and reads that akisa will be
meeting with the eighth today akisa and
the others meet and he tells the diary
owner that he's thinking of handing her
over to yuki out of the remaining three
contestants he says that he's most
suited to become god he tells them that
he thinks yuno is plotting something and
doesn't trust her one bit suddenly large
black orbs begin appearing all over the
city the world is ceasing to exist due
to deus death the only way to fix it is
to become god and save the world akisa
visits deus to discuss with him a
certain matter will it be possible to
save all of those who've died once a
diary owner becomes god learning some
important news he leaves deus world to
deliver yuki a message meanwhile yuki
runs to find the eighth's whereabouts he
finds the eighth hiding along with his
friends from school hinata here tells
him to stop hunting the eighth gods
can't bring people back to life suddenly
yuno calls and says that they're all
planning to betray him he points the gun
back at hinata and shoots her moving on
to the next he mows his friends down one
by one before moving on to the final
target suddenly akisay shows up and
tells him to stop akisa kisses him
turning her into a violent killing
machine they fight it out but she ends
up getting the upper hand slitting his
throat okay what the heck is going on in
the past few days yuki here has
experienced some crazy ass [ __ ] giant
black orbs that are making the world
disappear akisa here has a secret crush
on yuki and the eighth's head is
hideously big for a girl of her size at
this point yuki has to be so confused as
to what the heck is going on heck he
must be wondering why deus decided to
nominate a 14 year old kid to be god of
the universe either way i'm pretty darn
sure that akisa is telling the truth and
you know here is hiding some deep dark
secret now ever up to me i would
probably be ready to give up and call it
a day honestly it might be better for
the universe that the eighth become the
next god instead of us she looks like a
nice caring person and might be
trustworthy enough to have her promise
us that she'll find a way to bring all
the people from this world back to life
if you really think about it being god
sounds like a whole lot of work and yuki
here should probably want to focus on
studying or something more normal they
find the eighth stuck under rubble where
she accepts the fact that she's going to
die yuno stabs her leaving only her and
yuki as the remaining contestants akisay
gets back up and tries to tell yuki the
truth but he can't speak because of his
injuries getting his phone out he gets
fatally wounded by yuno before showing
him a text on his phone suddenly his
head falls off of his body that's when
their diaries tell them that the world
is going to end on july 28th a day
before the world ends yuki confronts
yuno about the lies that she's been
telling him suddenly she grabs an axe
and swings it into the ground she tells
him that she was lying to make him happy
since everyone was going to die anyway
he forgives her but mentions that the
message akisa showed said that yuno has
become god and went back in time that's
when she swings the axe towards his
direction shocked he runs out of the
house and muramura pushes him into a
massive hole he falls down into a dream
state looking at a replay of the past
and murder murder reveals that the world
they're in is a second world she
transports yuki to the causality
cathedral where the winner will soon be
announced suddenly yuki begins falling
and she announces that yuno is set to
become god that's when the knight comes
out of nowhere and saves him they're
transported two years into the past
where the world is back to normal
they've now created a third world
meaning that the evil you know is here
and she's going to kill her own copy to
keep meaning yuki and relive the same
events the ninth explains to yuki that
the easiest way to fix everything is to
find the original yuno and kill her the
ninth leaves them together saying that
this is far she's gonna go yuki walks
through his old school watching as his
diary shows that the original yuno is
about to attack he leaves the classroom
to find the original yunna waiting for
him they fight it out as murder murder
tries to help her kill yuki yuki runs
towards yuno and gets a knife thrown
towards his face he manages to avoid it
and the knight comes back to stop murder
murder from interfering with their fight
he tackles her to the ground and says
that she needs to go back to the second
world and become god there suddenly days
is core the massive flying object knocks
yuki over he wakes up in his own house
where his parents are still alive and
together confused he runs upstairs and
finds yuno staring at him from above she
explains that this is a world she
created where all of yuki's dreams have
come true he tries calling out to her
but yuno doesn't exist in this world and
he can't even say her name yuki tells
her to go back to the second world and
become a god if she does then the yuki
that she knows will disappear okay at
this point let's be honest nothing makes
sense the ninth has come back from the
dead there's multiple eunos running
around all over the place and i'm
beginning to forget the point of this
whole mobile death game in the first
place remember when this entire thing
was straightforward yeah neither do i
either way if i'm yuki i'm looking to
get rid of anything you know or you know
related seriously this girl has enough
problems to last an entire season of dr
phil and if i was dark to phil i would
say i've had enough whether or not we
can reset the world it doesn't matter
we've come this far and that means
there's no turning back folks however
looking at the current situation this
might be the best possible scenario
right now yuki's been given everything
he's ever wanted a stable family a life
with no worries and certainly no diary
owners trying to brutally kill him if we
think about it it might be just in our
best interest to forget everything that
ever happened and pretend the whole
thing was a crazy dream not only that
we've been thrown back into the past
meaning we can fix any mistakes we've
made past any tests we failed and go
find another girlfriend that's not as
nuts the possibilities are endless and
they're all positive she wishes him
farewell but gets confronted by the
ninth she attacks her but murder murder
interrupts and takes the ninth on by
herself yuno stares at her second world
counterpart getting ready to kill her
and continuing the cycle of the survival
game she wakes up and the original yuno
explains to her that life as she knows
it is about to get much worse whipping
out a knife she gets ready to kill the
helpless girl meanwhile the police have
arrived at the scene and the entire city
wonders what's happening on the school
roof yuki walks towards herself and
stabs her suddenly her dad shows up and
guards his daughter from being killed
the mother appears right after and
breaks down on the spot the original
yuno realizes that yuki changed their
futures meaning that all of their
childhood traumas would go away she
decides to kill the entire family but
the detective fourth shows up and shoots
her mid-sprint murder murder catches the
bullet and yuki shows up in front of
yuno he tells her to kill him and become
god but she can't find the courage to do
it she decides to take the final blow
dying in yuki's arms he's instantly
crowned the winner of the survival game
and the entire world is brought back to
normal now ten thousand years have
passed since yuki became god no one even
knows his name and yuno lives out her
days feeling as if she's missing
something important he wonders every day
what happened to yuno in the third world
after he disappeared with only a single
diary entry to keep him sane and if you
don't want to become the most powerful
owner of all time then like comment let
us know what you liked and of course
didn't like don't check out the holiday
playlist down below